let's read about Dan Savage
what his recipe might be for a
successful relationship check it out I
think being good to each other taking
care of each other and not taking each
other for granted and to try to put they
keep things in perspective you know as a
relationship adviser what I'm constantly
noticing is people who are obsessed with
the things in their relationships that
annoy them and they can be very
articulate and long-winded about their
partner's faults or the things that
they're dissatisfied with in the
relationship and nowhere near as
long-winded or articulate about their
partners strengths or what's good about
the relationship I call it paying the
price of admission in a long-term
relationship there are things about your
partner there are edges you're gonna
want to stand off there are things that
as you come together you're gonna carve
a groove in each other so you fit
there's no the one there's no perfect
person for you there's maybe a point six
four and you round that guy up to one or
that woman up to one or that's some
other point along the gender spectrum up
to one you make them the one that's an
act of will that you did for them and
they're doing the same for you to make
that happen under that's an
under-recognized need in a relationship
because people are saying I want the
person who I will then never ever change
or right and in practice no such a
person exists you're not finding them
because there's seven billion people and
that person doesn't exist even inside a
seven even as seven billion that person
even if we get to seven trillion that
person does not exist
so people grind against each other
people annoying each other so the inter
in math you might call that the
intersection function that function will
in any healthy relationship need to be
continually adjusted and modified right
but my point is with the price of
admission as you sand off the edges you
can send off so you fit together more
comfortably but then you have to
identify those things that no matter how
much you [__] and complain about them
will never change and you have to ask
yourself is this person worth paying the
price mission to put up with that and
not put up with it and complain about it
and guilt them about it all the time put
up with it and shut up about it
so we have to weigh the rest of the
relationship and say that it's worth it
right that is a really interesting thing
that you said and he said because we
there's all kinds of psychological
things about making a happy relationship
but we look in the brain at happy
relationships and try to see which parts
of the brain become active in a really
good relationship and the main part is a
brain region which linked with what we
call positive illusions the simple
ability to overlook what you don't like
about a human being and focus on what
you do and actually that's what he was
saying
[Music]